What are some of the things
that you do in your life
or words that you've heard
or lessons that you've internalized
to help you move through
the difficult moments in life?
You have to get used
to being criticized.
I've often been ridiculed
for believing in blockchain technology.
I've been treated like that
from friends and families
because I'm a visionary.
I personally think
AI's gonna be in the
similar place blockchain's at
in about three or four years.
They got infinite money now.
We had infinite money
five years ago.
It's the same stuff.
But the real builders
are gonna stick around
and they're gonna make
innovation and things happen.
So that's what I'm here for.
Cool.
I could drop the mic
right now if it
didn't belong to me.
Dude.
That's fucking...